the January 6th committee doesn't have
much time left because Republicans are
taking over the house in January and
Republican Adam kinzinger now says that
Donald Trump absolutely is guilty of
crimes committed in advance of January
6. there's a report from the hill
congressman Adam kinzinger republican
from Illinois said Wednesday that former
president Trump is quote absolutely
guilty of a crime surrounding the
January 6 riot at the Capitol I think
he's guilty of a crime this is a quote I
mean look he knew what he did we've made
that clear he knew what was happening
prior to January 6th he pressured the
Justice Department officials to say hey
just say the election was stolen and
leave the rest to me and then the
Republicans all need to put the stamp of
approval on it kinzinger told CNN's Jake
Tapper on the lead
quote I think he is absolutely guilty if
he is not guilty of some crime of some
kind of a crime I mean what we've
basically said as presidents are above
the law and they can do everything short
of a coup as long as it doesn't succeed
kinzinger said though he gave the caveat
that even as a member of the January 6th
panel he doesn't have the doj's power to
press charges well that we know
you could make the case that over the
four years ending on January 6 2021 or
January 10 2021. Donald Trump committed
dozens of counts of obstruction
put that aside from possible sedition
based on his actions Myriad conspiracy
charges of all kinds associated with the
Republican coup attempt mishandling of
classified documents taking classified
documents and then in addition to that
minimum on the criminal side think about
all the potential civil claims that
could be made
reminder that is important which is if
and until we have reason to revise our
belief
it is pretty widely known that the
Department of Justice
to some degree accepts that the
president is above the law not in a
literal sense but there is this
convention that has taken place and
until we actually see the doj behave
differently we don't really have a
reason to revise that perspective so the
January 6 committee will be meeting next
week that they announced that yesterday
uh it's gonna it's described as a
business meeting business for them is a
little bit different than what we
consider to be business but presumably
they will be meeting to make a decision
as to what if any criminal referrals
they are going to make the news from
last week the January 6th committee will
be making criminal referrals will they
in that in in fact do that and against
whom remains to be seen good habits have
to be sustainable in order to become
habits it has to be something you'll
actually do and when it comes to
nutrition some people have hours to plan
out every meal their exact vitamin
intake I'm not doing any of that I don't
have the time here's what's sustainable
for me I start my day with just a single
scoop of ag-1 from athletic greens it
gives me the entire day's worth of the
75 high quality vitamins minerals and
probiotics I want from whole food
sources it's just simple it's just one
scoop of ag1 I get all the nutrients I
want I don't have to do any math use my
protractor my ti 83 or take a bunch of
different capsules and pills it's not
some kind of wacky supplement making a
bunch of crazy claims you know I would
not promote something like that ag1 is
just a simple product that does what it
says it does it gives you the daily
nutrients and vitamins you likely want
vitamin A C E magnesium zinc potassium
in one simple scoop you keep your body
nourished you'll also get a free year
supply of vitamin D which I take in the
winter plus five free travel packs at
athleticgreens.com Pacman the link is
down below